it is already europe's worst refugee
crisis since the second world war and
this conflict isn't yet two weeks old
ukrainians are leaving their country any
way they can
this was a ferry crossing the danube
river in the south of the country
no one that we've spoken to wanted to
make this journey
and they all blame one man how do you
feel about terrorists i feel the same to
the vladimir putin i feel okay about
russians i have a lot of relatives in
the russia i studied in russia for four
years i feel okay about this country i
feel bad about the president and the
government in general because it's not
fair to the nation to his and to our
work
this is what it's like traveling the
other way there are a few people making
the journey taking supplies into ukraine
or going to fight the russians
they don't worry about those twice i've
taken supplies with the bus
and now i took the bus to go and bring
some more
in peacetime this was a wedding hall at
a smart hotel it is now a refuge for
families broken up by war
that's where donations are from people
we also have posters there as well
and people are arriving
constantly yes they come and go come and
go come and go every day
for some of them it is a chance to sleep
the first they've had in days
they huddled together around mobile
phones to listen to president
zielinski's latest address rallying
calls to a nation under fire
axana was a teacher in kiev her husband
a theater actor has stayed behind to
fight having fled herself she is now
helping other refugees i was so scared
about how it would be here so many
refugees so many people and so cold
but
yesterday when i come through the
border
with all these people all these romanian
people
liking
angels they
take us off
took us with their
rings wings yeah and
um and surrounded surrounded us with
segments warm and hospitality and love
and they do everything that our
suffering would be less
we've met lawyers and waitresses shot
workers and journalists housewives and
grandmothers
a few weeks ago
everyone you see in these pictures had
their own lives and identities
war has robbed them of so much
alistar bunker sky news